we should go to back to nordici's game  and uh I like the plan I showed is very  very easily winning but there is a late  in four in this position which was just  point at that point allows to us to to  our by our producer and if I tell you  it's my 10-4 you will find it instantly  right probably not actually  um  oh  yeah this yeah okay this very nice  yeah it's just yeah King H7 Knight F7  and then we give a made from one of the  four squares that is really really nice  yeah I mean anything wins what what he's  played also wins very comfortably but  okay but that's really that's a really  sweet way of finishing okay it's it's a  bit of a Pity it hasn't happened but  thanks for the hint Tad that that's yeah  that was worth that was definitely worth  seeing absolutely yeah very very much  appreciated I should I should say for  those those watching you there's someone  the amino screes